[Musica]
come prima cosa Volevo raccontarvi un
po' di come mi hanno contattato e gli
organizzatori del tedx e quando l'hanno
fatto Mi hanno detto che il tema di
questo Talk sarebbe stato lo
spazio-tempo Ovviamente io la laureata
in fisica la prima cosa che mi è venuto
in mente è
stata parlarvi dello spazio-tempo no di
come la concezione e dello del tempo e
dello
spazio vada oltre diciamo la nostra
intuizione quotidiana ma prima di questo
mi mi è arrivata Mi è venuta una visione
di quando io ero piccola
e vivevo in campagna e mio papà mi Ehm
mi portava nei boschi mi faceva vedere
le stelle e e per però in campagna C ci
sono anche le lucciole Quindi io mi
ricordo di queste lucciole che
viaggiavano adesso ok Questo sono io e
queste lucciole che si mischiavano
diciamo alle stelle in cielo e io da
piccola piccola avre avuto du 3 anni mi
chiedevo se fossero la stessa cosa no E
già da quel momento io mi sono accorta
che nutrivo non so un un fascino verso
la natura verso tutto ciò che ci
circondava e e e mi sentivo non so
avvolta eh in questa nella bellezza
diciamo no mi sentivo protetta mi
sentivo sicura
eh questa parte di sensibilità se
vogliamo chiamarla così E questa parte
di sentirsi unita a tutto ha anche
un'altra un'altra faccia che è quella
della consapevolezza
e la la consapevolezza è la paura eh del
futuro no del eh nel chiedersi ma perché
siamo nati Perché Eh Che senso ha la
vita e che senso ha eh la morte
soprattutto una grande consapevolezza
nei confronti della morte no e e mi
sentivo trasportata in questo flusso
irrefrenabile che
sarebbe finito con appunto la fine della
nostra vita e quindi questa è sempre
stata un'angoscia che mi sono portata
dietro fin da quando ero piccola e
queste sono paure che in realtà anche
gli adulti hanno e però mano mano che si
cresce una persona impara sempre di più
a diciamo sorpassare l'ostacolo no si
inventa gli adulti si inventano un sacco
di cose
per non pensare alla morte e però
nonostante questo c'è questa paura di di
base no E ma perché io vi sto
raccontando di queste cose molto tristi
perché per farvi capire che in realtà
molte volte noi associamo la scienza ha
pura tecnica quindi noi pensiamo che sia
completamente distaccata dall'emotività
invece io nei miei canali di
divulgazione cerco di far capire che la
scienza nasce da un'esigenza umana
esattamente nello stesso modo come nasce
l'arte no come i pittori utilizzano la
scrittura la pittura la musica per
incanalare diciamo questa necessità e
anche gli scienziati lo fanno perché
vogliono rispondere alla domanda eh alle
domande che di cui vi ho parlato prima
no di conseguenza Ok le emozioni sono il
carburante che guida la scienza però lo
fanno in un altro modo in un modo più
analitico più quantitativo più razionale
no ed era in un certo modo quello che
che serviva a me questa è la foto di me
e mio papà perché purtroppo Eh queste
crisi esistenziali cioè questi domande
che avevo si sono ampliate quando
avevo 14 anni perché mio padre è mancato
e quando lui lo ricordo come un artista
No lui era un pittore era una persona Io
sono cresciuta in un mondo artistico ho
fatto liceo artistico ho fatto
l'Accademia di belle arti e poi mi sono
spostata verso la scienza No questa
sensibilità me l'ha sicuramente
trasmessa lui e di conseguenza la mia
mio bisogno di di certezze e si è
ampliato sempre di più perché come vi
dicevo io ho perso mio padre All'età di
14 anni che è un po' quel periodo di
mezzo dove le persone iniziano a
rendersi conto a far finta che esista la
morte e e cercano di diciamo sorpassare
questo ostacolo mentre per me è stato la
goccia che ha fatto traboccare il vaso e
mi ha fatto sprofondare nelle crisi
esistenziali come un filo che si è rotto
queste crisi esistenziali mi hanno
spinta sempre di più cercare un senso io
questa enorme sensibilità eh questa
enorme adesso questa sensibilità ce l'ho
sempre avuta come vi dicevo Ma è stato
una di quelle cose che ovviamente come
potrete immaginare ha segnato
profondamente la mia vita e mi ha
avvicinato a però alla filosofia e ehm
che Esatto una delle domande che mi
ponevo e che cos'era che cosa fosse la
realtà e avevo bisogno però dopo aver
scoperto la filosofia che le risposte
che cercavo le
volevo tramite un mezzo che sembrasse
quasi inattaccabile ovvero io vedevo
nella ragione nella razionalità qualcosa
che non poteva essere contestato e
soprattutto volevo
verificare le mie ipotesi No avevo
bisogno che le le le risposte che
cercavo fossero dimostrabili e questo
quindi mi ha portato alla fisica Io mi
sono iscritta a fisica dopo come dicevo
aver fatto il liceo artistico e dopo
aver conosciuto la filosofia e
eh per rispondere a queste domande No
perché voi penserete che la fisica non
c'entra niente con la filosofia in
realtà la la fisica nasce è una branca
della scienza che nasce al nell'800
prima esisteva la filosofia della natura
di conseguenza è molto interconnessa
perché cerca di rispondere a queste
domande in modo più
quantitativo una delle dei motivi no che
vi dicevo questo scorrere del nel il
tempo che ti porta inesorabilmente alla
fine
e mi ha sempre affascinato i sempre
cercato di capire che cosa fosse il
tempo no che Che cos'è questo fluire
libero del tempo in cui ognuno di noi è
immerso no E pensavo che grazie all la
fisica io potessi trovare una
modellizzazione matematica che mi
avrebbe fatto scoprire che cosa fosse il
tempo e in effetti in un certo modo ho
capito la scienza fino a che punto si è
spinta per rispondere alle domande che
cosa sia il tempo allo stesso modo però
però mi sono accorta che e ci sono
domande alle quali non potremmo mai
rispondere oppure potremmo rispondere ma
chissà Tra quanti anni quindi in un
certo senso ti devi fare Te ne devi fare
una ragione quindi oggi io voglio
cercare di farvi capire che cos'è il
tempo ma in fisica il concetto di tempo
si collega anche al concetto di spazio e
adesso vedremo come noi
eh il tema è il tempo no la concezione
che abbiamo tutti del tempo è che scorre
inesorabile E noi siamo in questo
background nel quale il tempo non è
influenzato dalla nostra presenza No
cioè second Noi guardiamo l'orologio
l'orologio ticchetta e il tempo va E noi
siamo inermi di fronte a al tempo questa
in realtà è una concezione
molto molto recente deriva da Isaac
Newton quindi nel
1700 in
realtà attualmente Noi abbiamo
un'altra visione del tempo di cui vi
parler erò Ma questo concetto deriva
Questa è una domanda che oltre a me come
dicevo I filosofi antichi Si si Si
chiedevano tra cui Aristotele e secondo
la concezione di
Aristotele il tempo non è altro che il
contare del cambiamento quindi il tempo
S è un fenomeno che si è una proprietà
che si manifesta solo quando le cose
accadono no quando ci sono dei
cambiamenti altrimenti il tempo non
esiste se qualcosa non cambia Allora non
c'è tempo come vi dicevo dopo di dopo
Aristotele arriva un altro fisico nel
nel nel 700 che si chiama Isaac Newton
che ci dà quella visione di cui vi ho
parlato prima quindi di questo
background fisso nel quale Il tempo
scorre indipendente da tutto in ogni
punto dello spazio dell'universo nello
stesso modo e gli dice ad Aristotele No
non è vero il tempo non è vero che è il
contale del cambiamento il tempo esiste
indipendentemente da quello che accade
no e la la percezione comune che abbiamo
è che sia legata al cambiamento e in
realtà Esiste un tempo assoluto e
indipendente in qualsiasi luogo
nell'universo Il tempo scorre nello
stesso modo in questa visione di Newton
il tempo e lo spazio sono due concetti
separati Quindi c'è il tempo e lo spazio
Dove avvengono i i i gli eventi il il
tempo è l'ordine con cui avvengono gli
eventi secondo Newton e lo spazio è Dove
avvengono gli eventi
e sono assolutamente indipendenti l'uno
dall'altro
Oki Ok dopo Newton e e questa è una
visione come vi dicevo che voi avete
confidenza perché la vivete tutti i
giorni ma nel 900 200 anni dopo Newton
arriva un altro signore che si chiama
Albert Einstein di cui magari avrete
sentito parlare che ha completamente
rivoluzionato la nostra concezione di
tempo e secondo Einstein il tempo
non è più quella cosa che non è
influenzata da dagli oggetti che stanno
all'interno del background ma anzi il
tempo è qualcosa di malleabile che noi
abbiamo non noi esseri umani e gli
oggetti
all'interno del background possono
modificare il tempo di conseguenza non
esiste più questa concezione di Newton
dove
abbiamo il tempo assoluto Ma esiste un
passato esiste un presente ed esiste un
futuro
e quindi Esiste il futuro esiste il
passato e all'interno tra passato e
futuro c'è una zona grigia che viene
chiamata presente questo qua è lo
spazio-tempo di Minkowski la
rappresentazione matematica di quello
che vi ho appena detto di secondo
Einstein il tempo diventa malleabile non
esiste più un unico presente quindi il
mio presente in questo momento è diverso
dal presente di tutti voi e il presente
di una persona che si trova e se una
persona vivesse sul Sole il presente la
differenza del presente tra tra me e
quella persona sarebbe di 8 minuti
mentre la differenza del presente tra me
e una persona che si trova su una
galassia oltre la Via Lattea ad esempio
su Andromeda sarebbe di 2,5 milioni di K
di anni luce di conseguenza di anni
Scusatemi di
conseguenza cambia completamente anche a
livello culturale l'idea di non avere
più un unico tempo l'idea di che non sia
più indipendente assoluto fa crollare
tantissime certezze rivoluziona
completamente anche la società del del
Novecento no anche dalel dal punto di
vista artistico questo ha avuto
tantissima influenza
ehm In che questa è di nuovo la formula
di di che cosa vuol dire che il tempo
non è assoluto no e immaginate
Praticamente per farvi capire meglio che
ci sia
ehm più vi vi trovate vicino a un
oggetto massivo Come ad esempio la super
ficie della terra La terra è un oggetto
massivo che fluttua nello spazio-tempo e
e e più per voi Il tempo
scorre velocemente lentamente più vi
allontanate Quindi se vi se vi trovate
in montagna il vostro tempo passerà più
velocemente così e questo è uno dei dei
modi in cui voi Vedete che il tempo
viene modificato in presenza di un
oggetto massivo ma anche se più voi vi
muovete veloce più il vostro vostro
tempo rallenta più vi muovete piano più
il vostro tempo va veloce Ok adesso non
questo non non lo vedete se andate in
macchina perché per riuscire a
visualizzare questa questo modifica del
tempo bisogna Avvicinarsi a velocità
prossime alla velocità della luce che è
il limite invalicabile ma noi Lo
sfruttiamo questa cosa nei GPS l'esempio
che fan tutti i GPS vengono utilizzati
con grazie alla relatività generale e
quindi una questione che riguarda anche
la nostra quotidianità per Einstein
un'altra cosa che rivoluziona
completamente la concezione del del
tempo e dello spazio come vi dicevo per
Newton lo spazio è il luogo nel quale
avvengono gli eventi mentre il tempo è
l'ordine per per Albert Einstein invece
non può esistere spazio e non può
esistere tempo quindi un evento che
avviene nel background avviene nello
spazio tempo quindi lo spazio e il tempo
si uniscono per formare un unico oggetto
matematico che noi lo utilizziamo nella
descrizione matematica che tra l'altro
viene
Eh lo spazio-tempo è quello che circonda
ogni cosa cioè se voi vi immaginate la
terra che nell'universo La Terra sta
nello spazio-tempo e lo spazio-tempo ha
quattro dimensioni tre spaziali e una
temporale tre spaziali vuol dire eh vi
spostate in avanti vi spostate a destra
vi spostate in alto e una dimensione
temporale e tutte queste dimensioni in
base a dove ti trovi nello spazio-tempo
si modificano e quindi anche il tempo e
questa tutto ciò lo lo ritroviamo nelle
equazioni di Einstein che sono queste io
qua Poi avevo scritto di non farvi
spaventare ma in realtà sono equazioni
che magari per ché ha una base
matematica dice Ah ok Vabbè è una è
abbastanza semplice ma in realtà R
chiude infinite equazioni e e c'è di
tutto qua dentro Cioè qua noi ritroviamo
la dimostrazione matematica di tutto
quello che vi ho detto ma troviamo anche
la dimostrazione matematica di che cosa
di Come finirà l'universo da da da come
è nato l'Universo No il big bang lo
troviamo in queste formule troviamo
qua che ne so i buchi neri le onde
gravitazionali e tutto questo con la
matematica che predice questi questi
fenomeni ma questo è un altro discorso
perché sennò mi dilungo troppo qui la
rappresentazione dello spazio-tempo
secondo Einstein che è brutta perché in
realtà dimensionale e lo spazio-tempo è
quadridimensionale quindi noi abbiamo
una visione limitata di che cosa sia
però per farvi capire Magari questa
qualcuna di voi l'avrà già vista che c'è
questa coperta sul quale che sarebbe lo
spazio-tempo sul quale viene messa
questa massa e è forma non solo ripeto
non solo la dimensione spaziale come
potete vedere lì ma anche la temporale
se lì vedeste il tempo vedreste che
vicino a quella massa Va più lento e
lontano va più veloce
ehm
qui Vabbè come viene deformato lo
spazio-tempo in base all'oggetto massivo
Poi ci sono i buchi neri che
teoricamente non si sa bene ma
potrebbero rompere addirittura lo
spazio-tempo
e poi c'è un'altra grande teoria che si
chiama meccanica quantistica che non
riesce a parlarsi con la relatività
generale tutto quello di cui vi ho
parlato è relatività generale che
descrive il macroscopico c'è un'altra
teoria che descrive il microscopico
Ovvero le particelle tutto ciò che ci
circonda che descrive in altrettanto
bene la lo spazio e il tempo ma ha una
concezione diversa rispetto alla
relatività queste due teorie non si
parlano e quindi noi qua fisici hanno un
problema un problema enorme che se
riuscissimo a risolvere in questo secolo
avremmo delle rivoluzioni pazzesche ma
anche dal punto di vista tecnologico
ehm ora io salterò le le possibile
soluzioni di questo di questa
incongruenza perché sennò non riesco a
finire il in tempo sappiate che ci sono
delle teorie che risolvono le
incongruenza tra meccanica quantistica e
relatività generale
e sono molto molto interessanti se vi
consiglio di andare a cercare qualcosa e
però volevo nell'ultimo minuto volevo
parlarvi anche di un altro progetto
perché io mi occupo di divulgazione
Attualmente mi sono laureata a marzo
quindi adesso mi occupo di di di parlare
della fisica e Ma sono anche Ambassador
di un altro progetto che si chiama
generazione Stem che cerca di far vedere
e la scienza da una chiave un pochino
più femminile perché e se noi chiediamo
a un bambino di rappresentare una
persona di di scienza questo bambino al
90% rappresenterà un uomo con la barba
No perché la donna per molto tempo è
stata preclusa dalla carriera
scientifica di conseguenza c'è un po' la
visione che uno scienziato sia un uomo
saggio e invece noi cerchiamo di
eh
risolverlo parlando Noi ragazze siamo 50
contributors e parlando di scienza a
360° sui canali online ma anche offline
andando nelle scuole ad esempio
e e quindi ci tenevo a a a dirvelo
perché se qualcuno fosse interessato
alle carriere scientifiche Può
contattarci perché a noi ci farebbe
molto piacere riuscire a ad aiutare chi
vuole affacciarsi questo mondo diciamo
basta